le choix européenne l'intégration
européenne c'est un choix de la
population geéorgienne et encore
récemment le l'opinion enfin le sondage
de l'opinion publique a montré que plus
de
80 5
% pour être plus exact 87 % de la
population geéorgienne soutient
fermément l'intégration européenne
et c'est ce gouvernement d' ur ce ce
Parlement a inscrit dans la Constitution
euh et c'était la volonté de du peuple
entier de de garantir cet axe de la
politique étrangère par la Constitution
donc c'est la Constitution qui prévoit
qui stipule que la priorité de la
politique étrangère de la Georgie est
l'intégration européenne et intégration
euroatlantique maintenant euh
il faut comprendre ça comme une commande
de la de toute la population quel que
soit le parti politique qui arrive au
pouvoir ils
seront ils seront à l'écoute de cette
commande du peuple et ils ne peuvent pas
dévier de cette de cette politique qui
qui a été
très rigoureusement prononcé et qui a
été inscrit dans la Constitution et puis
aussi si vous regardez les événements
politique aucun autre sujet politique ne
peut faire
sortir une telle quantité de la
population dans la rue que quand il
s'agit de l'avenir européenne ou de de
réaffirmer euh son attachement et sa
fidélité à la politique européenne de la
Georgie